schlecht mein gott hat ihn doch einfach
die sachen aus der kiste
ich habe ihn einfach getötet weil er wie
schnell getötet hast du bist mir raus
locker ich bin schon draußen
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zurück zu minecraft über auf
dem hexenberg texas dem virus aber ich
bin noch in diesen fakten schiff hier
drin wo ich die ganzen mops umlagern und
lena wollte mich in dieser folge rückten
aber du musst dann erst mal du musst mir
versichern dass ich nicht sterben ich
reinkomme du erst in der menge im ok
drum rum aber die sollte es eigentlich
kriegen und wenn nachts wenn gleich
wieder tag ist obwohl es gerade es nach
geworden oder
also was ist wenn ich jetzt sterben so
ja das sind sie keine ahnung was dann
ist ein bis er tot
wir hörten haben wir dann will ich dich
ja nich trend harrow ist das portal
überhaupt weil simon im haus doch oder
ja weil sie mal ein neues ass jo
natürlich weiß man jetzt ist das schon
wieder so eine spinne ich muss da
irgendwie blöcke hinsetzen und sich
daher schwimmen kann und da sind einfach
tausende spinnen und die guckt mich
einfach alle an
ich kann hier nicht lebend weg kommt es
ist unmöglich es erhältlichen electric
stuff dann direkt aber ich bin umzingelt
von mobs ich bin um zielt auch jetzt
daran aber wer's portal ist verschlossen
ja ja ich war da ja auch noch niedrigere
keine ahnung
wenn ihr jetzt wegen der sterbe luca
okay dann ist das ihr inventar ok oh
mein gott habe überlebt okay gut kommt
mir okay okay ist meine stadt mehr wird
wo ich mir aufgabengebiet ich bin nach
bretten gebiet ich komm ich raus weil
die tür verschlossen ist und mein gott
es kann nicht sein es kann nicht die tür
verschlossen
ja wir kommen jetzt raus alter du darfst
du blöcke kaputt machen
naja man dann bin ich quasi tot ich bin
inmitten von 2000 piratenschiff oder
darf ich in solchen notfällen was
dadurch ich weiß nicht ich werde dich
retten so zu sagen aber das kann nicht
sein dass hier so viele spinnen sind ich
wollte es einfach welche hier macht es
einfach jolo ich mal als hier die tür
auf ich boxe einfach alle mops die
de-mails bin ich schon jetzt mächtig en
retten
damit musste jetzt damit leben dann
gleich also darf ich kaputt machen
von juliane es einfach richtig freuen
sich einfach gerne boxee box botox botox
nein das gibt es nicht ich bin so dumm
ich glaube ich jetzt immer weiter vor so
ein bisschen ich hab so eine geheime
konstruktion kaputt gemacht ich wollte
ich aber nicht
lena du blöd aber das ganz cool jetzt an
schlagloch was ist denn ich muss nichts
kaputt man hier sonst die clevercard auf
und zu machen
wir schalten darf man drücken glaube ich
also das ist ja nicht kaputt machen
ja ich hab's kaputtgemacht auszuwählen
das ist schon falsch aber ich habs nur
gemacht man jung ist innehalten weil die
kräfte gesagt hat ja weil ich ihn retten
muss in welche wasser kohle hat man sie
laufen mit schwimmer ganz kurz ich will
dich greifen schön macht ich schreibe
dir ich werde von irgendwo attackiert an
ich mit vergifteter kinos fix aber ich
kann was ich schreibe den chat das ist
das in der mitte ist ja nur die höhe und
das andere ist das ist nicht erfasst
das und und 27
das ist das andere also man muss ich
genauso ok power label was ich zum guten
schuhe an
wobei mir aber jetzt geht
da war aber papa puma puma facto um ein
grad voll spaß mit den schuhen momente
mein gott das wasser mit die dümmste
entscheidung meinem leben gerade was
spaß macht habe ich habe mir so einen
richter dachte ich mache mir so ein
killer weg und auf einmal war da ein
skelett und jetzt siehst du mich die
ganze zeit ob du musst mich als trainer
ja ich kann mir schon so kein link in
einer schlucht tun oder so nee das ist
so
piratenschiff zwischen zwei türen das
ist halt auf dem wasser bisschen erwarte
ich laufe aber auch noch danach ein
bisschen oben eine spur gehen dabei voll
kaputt bringst du musst wieder live in
der ard ich geb dir alles in mich lebend
raus holt na ja kein link wenn king am
eingang auf die urwahl wir angefangen
haben
wir haben nur 15 minuten das wird dieses
mal rechtzeitig alte mann aber es war
wahlkampf von mir alter ich schieße
einfach pfeiler des todes viele ich
glaube gerade die ganze wärme die ich
hier gerade töte an den leuten junge du
ahnst es nicht wie viele zombies sind
ich hab noch nie so viele zombies auf
einem haufen gesehen mein gott ist ein
riesen mehr egal wenn du das leben mir
das leben schaffen dann kriegen wir so
was von viel erfahrungen
ich finde es auch wichtiger wer sich ich
glaube wir könnten friedensnobelpreis
vielleicht bekommen wir trotz krieg
einfach man dort mit dem zug kam über
wasser laufen ist ab jetzt guck mal bei
irgendwie mal zu mir alter ich bin
gerade am sterben jetzt regnet auch noch
halt noch richtige erzähle man zu den
koordinaten nein ich habe gefällt warum
soldaten falsch abgelesen junge ist
regelt und spritzen jetzt bringt sich
nicht mehr im wasser
es ist jetzt mehr dunkle länder mal ganz
kurz den shader zwingende man man kann
nicht spritzen im einmal aufgehört zu
sprinten ist wenn ich mit einem meer der
hier ist ein bisschen kacke sie müsse
erst noch so ein ding gelaufen ich bin
so dumm ich hasse mich wie war nochmal
die kunden haben ich kann gar nicht im
chat ich nehme gleich mal ganz kurz den
keller rauschte - 4200 ist die erste ok
und 2700 ist die zweite möchte ich bin
mehr als 2.200 bei der zweiten aber ich
muss kurz zurückschwimmen
und wenn wir neuen anlauf zu machen weil
man darf nicht aufhören zu spinnen euro
aufwärts zu sprinten dann versinkt man
im wasser alter und das ist einfach nur
tragisch ich möchte menschen in der
lobby
ich muss jetzt mal wirklich ganz gut
ohne schilder spielen weil sonst darf
ich das schaffe ich das hier gar nicht
also wie viel war das zweite 2700 die
richtung ok oh mein gott man fliegt er
da mal was was aber man darf nicht auch
wenn beim aufentern zu steigern
dann geht man einfach unter 6.000 macht
tutoria von den ami funktionieren die
schon damals selbst danach falsch ist es
dann schon über ist es also ein schiff
was ich sehe was dem ich irgendetwas
komisches finden
das ist mir sind zwei riesige türme die
du siehst ok ich sehe sein chef jetzt
ein riesiges ungefähr bei seiner
position
jetzt gab er beim kombi als sind ganz
viele brote habt ihr zu sprinten ich hab
keine ahnung aber egal ob garten boot
gefunden
mit an bord der klar dass wir die sache
ich mache mir ein boot und dann fahre
ich irgendwie weg der noch gleich da
sterben ein turm
ich sehe hier modulen unten in den boden
ganz schiff eben zwischen zwei jahren
mein gott wie studier mit dem kopf da ja
ich komme ich meine ich meine
wahrscheinlich spaß aber wir sind ja gar
nicht mehr soviel monster ja mein sport
kaputt gemacht ist sie voll guter [ __ ]
euch doch alle keine der hier warte ich
hieß ja alle ab die dazu nahe kommen den
habe ich das bin ich nicht passt auf was
hinter mir
das bin ich nein ich habe auf die dings
geschossen dabei lasst mich richtig
abgeschossen nein ich hab dachte ich bin
geschossen das war den turm zusammen
machen weil machen ja okay was los jetzt
geht's los alter tender über das ist
wenn ihr nicht reingefallen
was ist das denn freundin super gut da
hätten so gut wie weg und was wirst du
den agent er erschießt mich ab denn
rette mich wer schafft das nicht ich bin
hinter die habe ich meinen schwindet
gewesen
überlebt das nicht ich habe vier herzen
der ja ich kann ihn einfach so gar kein
kind ja
wie viel ich hatte vorhin dreieinhalb
jetzt habe ich fünfeinhalb noch die
kälte da nicht ich weiß es nicht
heftig ich wo ich hab nur alles möglich
hier gesehen
ja da habe ich ihm gefällt weil ich dich
mag du kannst es nicht alt aber jetzt
heute wieder die bogen skills roth
becker ja ich komme zu dir und ihm dann
und diesen so halb verbunden
wenn du hast du da halb im eimer dass
jetzt nichts drin mexiko beteiligt die
sachen die mir dann kriegen
ok ja ja ja mit thema nur eine harte
zeit rein
ein letzter zeit hinterher das ist ein
richtig gutes und was das für einer der
schon wieder so gut da luca dem
spinnennetz
ich brenne macht die dinger capo gott
hinter dir ging hier drin
hier müssen die sparer kaputt man dabei
nichts gut ist denn hier ist nicht okay
jetzt erstmal ganz gut hat aber irgend
so eine arme gedroppt fries blätter kann
über wasser laufen
so warte ganz kurz ein thema ganz gut
man inventar bis neu macht das ruhig ich
habe kein problem damit
lasst ihr euch zeit online gab aber für
dieses feuer den habe ich noch nie
gesehen das sind natürlich zwei auf
einmal von den gewesen
ja man ihm an mega heftig wie lang
dauert zehn minuten noch alles drin was
oft hat irgendjemand geschossen als er
in wedding an das ein richtig gutes geld
vorausgehen leser bleibt trennen sich
der anwender so findest du siehst du
dich an hörste besser raus zu gehen
ich geh jetzt mal ganz gut jetzt
wahrscheinlich alle dem anstieg kam das
und so heftig für heftig deftig gemacht
natürlich schon gesagt als ich gesucht
hat noch zehn minuten nun jetzt dass du
sagst immer noch zehn minuten
nein wir sind jetzt zehn minuten ok wenn
du das sagst klar sein skelett was ich
tue mir eben die unnötige sachen da
wieder rein
ja es mag ja study on level zum kristall
bogen ist ja verzaubert wie gut 21 egal
wer gerne geld braucht eben bei dem
wetter noch mal eben durch einen
bekommen dankeschön fackeln bräuchte man
nicht alles passte zusammen also sachen
hier an
wie werde ich dennoch haben wir keines
bonner kaputt gemachte da fallen die
uniklinik homburg
jetzt kommt mit einem herz an aber ich
hab kein bock auf ihn noch weiter tot
tot
ich war erstmal schießen tot tot tot
ich möchte nur den vorne japan tralala
denn der kommt hoch ich bin auch schon
da hallo ich musste erst das essen immer
mit der ruhe alles da ist nicht so gut
jaja tralala lalalalala da kommt einer
und drei verweisen auf den 200 geflogen
bis die beiden gefehlt habe ich fahre
weiter
hast du schon die sachen ja ausgenommen
nein da sind einfach nur die kag sachen
drin alter da war ja nur leckeres essen
oder eisen und kohle drin
ja ich auch jetzt war wichtig weil
willst du cool suchen nein aber ein paar
gute sachen drin
ich hab dir das beste aber drin gelassen
ernsthaft hektisch weil ich gebe dir
nach ein paar sachen ab danke halle
spinne magic essenzen alter davon kann
ich auf welche abgeben
ja danke hatte ich nehm das er heute
electric essenzen das ist das was ich am
meisten braucht von allen sachen okay
ich brauchen und mehr ist mäßig hab ich
zu hause ein bisschen was also ich
brauche vor allem so spezialisten nicht
mehr gott heute in den natürlichen doch
einfach die sachen einfach getötet weil
er wie schnell getötet hast mir raus
locker ich bin schon draussen zu sein
ist die obere kiste ist nicht genommen
luke reiße man verlieren stimmen wir
sind zu dumm man hasst ihn gezielt zu
schnell
ja dann gehen wir vielleicht aber hoch
meint extrudiert jetzt doch
luca egal während um daneben
das war echt trumpf ich wollte meine
stärke raushängen lassen schnell gekühlt
das alte werden einfach direkt tot das
baby metal dance und wie gesagt ist
einfach gut wenn du das sagst sowie
gehen jetzt die untere etage dann muss
ich ganz gut da unten drin war ich
eingegraben da drin
robert software passierte nichts na ja
geht schon kaputte läuft schon bei dem
trumm was drin hast dem schiff als
ausgenommen da war nicht viel drin warte
ich muss ganz kurz meine tasche packen
tasche
der turm ist die mega leicht bald immer
nur ein sport will halt nicht warte
heute nicht auf mich dann gleich mal ist
die peter mieth von der kdk speedrun ich
mache eine speed aber lass mir so viel
spaß macht und ein wenig gleich sterben
etwa jetzt schon vergiftet er ich bin
ein spa steven hab ich das du getan hast
du ich hoffe jetzt auch so schnell nach
oben ich will auch noch oben jetzt wo
mein gott warum hast du dieses wahlrecht
kaputt supergut spinner oder landen doch
ein gast bei mir hat bei mir sagt bei
mir hatte den habe ich noch da ist noch
dabei mir ein bisschen geharkt ja ich
bin jetzt aus dem fenster gesprungen
warum nicht so gut waren ehrlich ja ich
nicht als ein hoch gelaufen das war voll
dumm von mir drk man hätte hin
ich bin mit hermann relativ weit oben
transport rein
naja das gut wie damals keine school of
scrap gemacht was das da kannst dich
nach hause teleportieren ja stimmen da
eigentlich nur noch fünf minuten alter
den turm schafft mir doch erwartet ich
bin ja ich will auch etwas wechselt
ihren ich hab miniatur rotes herz
crafting altenwald ich mal das ist
richtig gut dass ich ja richtig geil
damit kannst du richtig gute sachen
machen alter wenn du das sagst da hab
ich gehört weiß ich habe davon keine
ahnung haben legal halbes halbes leben
halbes leben halbes leben denen je nach
wetter nach halbes leben das solltest du
das schaffen probierstube städten rette
mich nett und immer der chart warte ich
bin unten solch hochkommen es läuft
wieder hier bei mir läuft wieder
derzeit komme ich freue mich jetzt schon
auf den moment wo ich das gleich alles
auspacken kann hier wie zu hause sind
wie lange wie lange die frage nach noch
vier minuten waren die folge fort den
boss beenden oder weil wir die vögel
noch bis zum boss machen nachdem etwa
dem was verenden reicht jetzt erstmal so
weit über halb kommen der krawall nicht
dass wir dann im kampf schnell wenden
müssen und dann sterben dass wir auch
hoffen dass so risiko westhoff com ist
mit hirn firma ich bin nach antalya oder
ist eine böse verzauberte spinne hat
wegen der winter gesprochen ich angst
vor der hatte aber die sind meistens
nicht mal gut aber ich hatte immer wenn
die so einen global oder wenn da oben so
skitrainer blablabla da hab ich mal war
ich sollte da bin ich früher immer
gestorben von den spaß dies vor allem
von den dingern die einen dann dies
sieht die schwerter wecken dem motto ich
bin irgendwie so blöd verzaubert ich
sehe ihn die alles richtig komisch ja
dass es wegen dieser spinne da die haut
ab was geworden
naja ich kriegte schaden dich kriege
schaden vielleicht mal gebremst
ja das kann sein danke du kannst du gut
1 und 1 zusammenzählt o bot über dir
über die über die app bei mir auch jene
die noch ne na.de japans ich muss raus
meine herzen sind schwarz ok woher das
kenn ich das doof ich habe angst ich
weiß nicht wie viel ich hab' ich bin
ganz unten ich komme wieder hoch eine
farbe wir müssen etwas zu viel angst
wieder raus in die chance herzlich
ich habe davon gewusst ja ich habe den
spaß die ddr zu schwarz gemacht habe ich
gekillt
ich glaube dass der becker kommt nämlich
auf weg ja ich bin wieder drin wo bist
du
etage über der glaube ich okay neues
buch ist noch sei der erste spaß macht
ja ja die hat spaß gemacht aber kämen
[ __ ] ob als warte warte warte springt
nicht raus wartet auf mich mein job vor
die sachen hier die teigtaschen runter
ja oh mein gott wer doch aufgepasst dies
und ihren folgen rüstung und so weiter
ich habe mein shader übrigens immer noch
aus nein man gleich wieder an wartet
kurz wenn die kämpfe vorbei sind
der fasst das great lakes habe ich
einfach mal gefunden
ja die laki das war meine nein
doch die ruhe war auch hier gebe ich die
gleichgewichte gleich noch mal ich habe
extra gekillt
ich möchte auch haben bitte ganz
deutschland ihr gleich mit dem teil
gefährlich mit tanja 5er bemerkt ein
eindeutiges tänzen ja wir teilen wir
auch wie sage ich hab dass dies diesmal
auf ihrer mutter und dann sagen wir okay
und anteil noch ein ich nehme auf wenn
nicht gar nicht kenne ich gar nicht geld
ja walter was wir sonst machen die na ja
ich weiß ich bin ja vertrauen
kaputtgegangen
ich muss ihn jetzt töten naja ich hab
ein getötet oh mein gott so schnell raus
hier
dialoge und hinter mir kraft alles ein
haben wir gehen auf die inseln und
teilen alles boa nein lacht bei mir
zuhört wir machen jetzt ein kater lange
gewänder nächst wollen zu mir nach hause
und dann teilen wir junge ich habe oben
gesehen aber noch fünf medical defence
drin und ich konnte ihn nicht nehmen
deswegen mich noch mal an die kiste
gegangen so richtig fies und böse wie
ich denn noch alles mitnehmen will sein
ganzes hab und gut bevor alles ein stück
das noch mal stark gemacht haben wir gut
gemacht alter richtig machen jetzt noch
kurz krieg nein wir brauchen uns einmal
mit der schaufel nicht dass einer
gestörten 123 ja okay das ist jetzt
genug krieg ich finde man muss auch ein
bisschen bisschen frieden und so haben
ja also vielen dank zu schauen wir sehen
uns morgen wieder hast du eigentlich nix
x mas gut